this is the dreambod l20 ultra the
latest and greatest all-in-one do-it-all
Robot vacuum sent to us and sponsored by
dream Tech now I've tested quite a few
robovacs and all of them seem to be
lacking in a couple of ways like having
to manually empty the trash pins as well
as simply not cleaning the floors as
well as I would have hoped but the l20
ultra is the first robovac that I've
seen that actually solves those issues
by both not skimping out on Common Sense
Tech as well as thinking up some really
clever technology that I've never seen
before so what I'm going to do is break
this review down into three pieces
number one will be my thoughts on the
hardware itself number two being the
actual cleaning performance including
the unique and clever technology and
number three will be my thoughts on all
the software and customization so let's
get right into it the unboxing and setup
was really quick easy and
self-explanatory with with mostly
everything already set up except for the
little ramp tray that you simply pop on
and the cool little bottle of cleaning
solution that plugs right into this
little slot on the inside of the base
station which also includes a handy
brush for cleaning which has an
integrated blade for removing hair from
the vacuum brush I love how it comes
with a flat low profile power plug and
you can wrap the cord up on the back so
it doesn't stick out of the sides the
base station is bigger than others on
the market but it's for good reason it
not only comes with two containers one
for fresh water and one for dirty water
that are completely sealed and easy to
remove and fill up or empty but it
actually supports hooking up a water
line directly into the base station so
you never have to fill the water tank up
manually and it also has another water
line to drain the dirty water basically
create getting a completely passive
mopping system and as far as the
vacuuming and dust side goes it also
comes with a built-in easily removable
dust bag that will fill up over time and
once full you simply pull it out which
will seal the back for easy disposal and
it comes with an extra bag on the side
now this is part of what makes the l20
ultra really special because unlike
other robovacs you don't have to
constantly and manually empty the
internal Dustbin every couple of days
this one does it automatically by using
this port that connects directly from
the inside of the robot vacuum all the
way into the base station and into the
dust bag so with that said the l20 ultra
is hands down the most passive and
worry-free robovac ever created now as
far as the vacuum itself setup is super
easy by simply popping on the little
spinning brush that collects debris
during vacuuming and both of the mop
pads which to my surprise magnetically
attach to the VAC it literally blew my
mind when I installed the app and had to
do a quick scan of my main level and it
actually dropped the mop pads and left
them behind in the base station while
scanning the main point of this magnetic
feature is that you can set the robovac
to automatically drop off the mod pads
at the base station whenever it detects
High pile carpets so that it doesn't get
them wet now there are also options to
lift the mop pads by up to 10.5
millimeters which is great for low pile
carpets and there's a mode to completely
avoid carpets altogether but getting
back to when I first had it scan my home
it came right back to the base station
and picked the mob pads up again so it
would be ready for cleaning and I really
love the accuracy of the map that it
made of my main floor showing off every
obstacle as well as shading in the area
in my living room that's covered up by
my rug but more on the app and software
later on in this video overall the
hardware was very well built with a
bunch of tech packed into the base
station including buttons on top for
quickly returning the VAC to the station
starting cleaning and manually enabling
the heated dry mode which will actually
dry the mop pads so they don't smell and
it was also cool to see that the robovac
itself came with lidar sensors at the
top with their Pathfinder smart
navigation AI action and 3D structured
light obstacle avoidance system which
works in real time to avoid bumping into
toys and everything else that you might
leave on your floor and of course it
comes with a bumper at the front for any
unexpected bumps like the super thin
legs on my entry table it also
surprisingly comes with two lights at
the front which automatically turn on
whenever it gets a bit dark in an area
to help it see and they're actually
super bright now getting into the actual
cleaning performance I was surprised by
the very high 7 000 pas of suction power
which picked everything up and did an
excellent job vacuuming the rug I could
pretty much hear the rug being deep
cleaned and scrubbed with good friction
so I know it got cleaned well but the
feature that really blew me away was
their world's first mop extend
technology that will actually swing out
one of the mobs to the side to get right
up against your walls and any Edge
getting within two millimeters of
baseboards and other edges which I
haven't seen on any Robot vacuum before
because it's a world's first and that
has actually been my biggest complaint
of other robot vacuums they just don't
get close enough to the wall when they
vacuum and mop so the edges have to be
washed manually but with the dreambot
l20 Ultra the right mop swings out to
cover every inch of flooring and it even
intelligently comes back in when the
robot vac rotates so it doesn't hit the
wall or other objects like the fridge
and then it instantly swings out again
so it doesn't miss any flooring I've got
to say this is by far the coolest
feature of the robovac and it makes it
Shine amongst the rest of the
competition I was also surprised how
well it puts pressure on the floors and
actually washes them well it pauses
every so often and comes back to the
base station for re-washing the pads
automatically and getting them damp
again so it's not just spreading dirt
all over the place it actually cleans
itself so for cleaning performance I've
got to say that the l20 ultra is by far
the best out of any robovac I've used
before and now let's get into the
software the app was really easy to set
up and I was impressed by how nice the
map looked of my main floor there was a
ton of customization in the app
especially for cleaning modes letting
you choose just vacuuming just mopping
both at the same time or vacuuming first
and then mopping you could also choose
the suction level which of course I
chose turbo and I set the mopping effect
to the wettest setting however you can
actually choose between daily mopping
intensive mopping and deep mopping which
basically reduces the cleaning spacing
and cleaning speed to improve the
mopping performance and to my surprise
even with turbo mode and the deepest and
wettest mop settings enabled it cleaned
my entire floor with 53 battery life
left over you can also go into the
self-cleaning settings and adjust the
frequency for returning to self clean
the mobs as well as enable either water
saving daily mopping or deep mopping
modes then you can also adjust the dry
mop pad setting to either two three or
four hours depending on what you want
and finally there's the auto empty
setting which makes it empty the Dustbin
either after every cleaning low
frequency which is every three cleanings
or it has an intelligent mode that'll
detect when it's full and empty it just
in case you have a ton of dust debris or
pet hair within the app there's a map
editing button which lets you set up
no-go zones different areas Furniture
carpet and a virtual passage and of
course there's even more settings for
setting up a schedule customizing the
carpet and floor cleaning settings
including carpet boost and some other
features like large particles boost and
AI recognition for pets but the craziest
features that you can actually access
the camera on the robot vac as well as
remote controlling it and turning on the
microphone so you can hear what's going
on inside your house and talk to anybody
in your home now this seems a creepy but
it does audibly say when the camera
turns on as well as when the microphone
turns on so anybody in the room will
know right away and dream Tech is
assuring that the camera data will only
be processed locally and will not be
uploaded to the cloud and the most
useful thing about this remote viewing
feature is that you can monitor your
home or take photos or videos in case
you're out of town and you think someone
may have broken into your house and if
so you can follow them around and tell
them that the cops are on their way to
scare them off but anyway this has got
to be the most high-tech robovac ever
created that basically covers all bases
including fully passive mopping with the
ability to hard connect it to your water
source and your drain and the mop extend
feature just takes the cake in terms of
having the best mopping performance out
there so if you're interested in
ordering the l20 ultra you'll find the
link down in the description and and
comment below thanks dream tech for
sponsoring this video and if you enjoyed
it you can subscribe above and check out
one of those two videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign